going on the Howard Stern was
embarrassing like a verbal speculum that
opened me up to a brand of vulnerability
I had never encountered and it was one
of the best experiences of my
professional life I'd always loved
Howard when he finally came on in LA in
1991 my radio mentor Tammy Hyde and I
would listen starting at 3 in the
morning as this new world of
broadcasting unfolded long before I even
dreamed of making him to be a reality
Howard in his first few days on the air
said something that profoundly affected
me and whenever I broadcast I think of
it to this day
if you have the opportunity to talk into
a microphone make sure you say something
be funny be smart give people something
to think about but know that it's an
honor and never waste a moment he was so
right and though back then I had not yet
broadcast my first show as a part-time
DJ I promised myself that if and when I
had that chance I would use my powers
for good lived up to that Kennedy I
would sprinkle my brilliance and wit on
eager listening ears or I would make
people vomit for Morrissey tickets Same
Same Same howard was reaching new levels
in 90's he came into the quintessential
radio town Los Angeles where people
spent the majority of time in their cars
and radio and his personalities are
staples and as important to people's
communities as gasoline and handguns
those who know the market well predicted
Howard would be a miserable failure in
LA this would be his Waterloo he was too
much of a New Yorker and no one would
want to hear his raunchy brand of self
focus he was diametrically opposite from
successful LA radio hosts Rick Dees mark
and Brian Jay Thomas now those were LA
success stories some Long Island
loudmouth would never gain the kind of
traction necessary to eviscerate and
dominate the competition like Howard had
in other markets
but I was excited to hear him surely
there were other people like me right
Oh hells yes and we were all realizing
and one relieved exhale just how [ __ ]
boring la radio really was sorry Rick it
took me a week to get used to Howard I
heard his best of compilations and was
well versed in the staff he kept around
and berated on the show Fred Robin Gary
but after the first few days I wondered
when he would stop talking to them and
get around to the show and then I got
hooked and that started a very unhealthy
Howard habit that had me listening live
to his broadcast on Kos X every morning
starting at 3:00 a.m. I was no longer
sleeping I stopped showering and was
twitchy without him during off-hours
Tammy and I actually called Gary in the
studio one morning because all infinity
stations had a directory of hotlines and
we could phone any sister station in the
country even WX RK can a rock in New
York holy [ __ ] we could reach Howard we
called it rang Gary
picked up and sounded more than a little
annoyed as obviously other overnighters
in various markets had had the same
bright idea and he seemed cheesed we
were wasting his time asking dumb
questions was Howard like can we go on
the air he was a good sport but these
queries wouldn't be answered in person
for another two years when I'd be a
guest on the house
unlike other radio or TV shows were the
hosts come out to greet you and fawn
over you before the broadcast you don't
meet Howard until you come face-to-face
with him in the studio and if you're
lucky you can hear his intro and then
some if he and Robin get sidetracked
detailing the story of your life before
you get in there no matter how much
press I'd done who I'd met and
interviewed in my few months at MTV
there was nothing as surreal as hearing
Howard Stern say my name and talk about
me as a nobody before I got to look into
his eyes he admitted he was doing this
minute he was doing his publicist a
favor by having me on a friend of my
manager had gotten the booking and the
intro was the equivalent of a broadcast
mercy [ __ ] if you were incredibly
unlucky he'd skewer you setting the
stage for your flame out as he
solidified people's impression of you
before you set foot in the studio and
tried to shovel the [ __ ] back into the
dead horse
many immortal had tried and failed
utterly to steer the topic of
conversation away from themselves and
their fart parts on Howard's show he
always gets him with the anus everyone
can handle boobs and wieners but mercy
the second he goes for the corn people
just panic I heard it a million times
everyone thinks they're gonna handle it
every sucker is a moralist who promises
to draw the line at buttholes but the
harder you fight the easier you fail I
screamed to the radio you just talk
about your ass it's it's no use there is
a scientifically proven direct
proportional relationship between
hesitation and acquiescence
when discussing one's own ass with
Howard Stern the harder you fight the
more you spill it is Howard's law of
course I was prepared to tell Howard how
he influenced my decision to pursue
broadcasting an easy job with good money
but I ended up for the first time
anywhere discussing in detail my
long-suffering virginity
it was something I'd alluded to on the
radio a subject addressed through
informal proxies who told my tight told
of my tight inaccessible quarters and
locked legs but I never tackled the
subject on my own in the press for the
world to hear there might have been
implications and inferences but the only
public declaration I made was on
Howard's show and it wasn't just about
my virginity which was a subject of
natural fascination to the world's great
vagine' ologist he also could not for
the life of him reconcile how I denied
myself the pleasure of vagina to penis
intercourse yet I'd allowed the bear in
the cave meaning I had engaged in mouth
to penis intercourse which gave me
virtually no pleasure but in his words
kept me in control he just kept saying
you let a man's penis in your mouth but
you won't have sex with him which is was
his only his estimation full of
half-truths but it made me laugh and I
had no answer for it I stammered and
blushed which is always plays well on
radio but I really had no answer because
I'd never thought about it in those
terms why were [ __ ] okay
pregnancy I guess he just kept playing a
bear sound effect over and over again
you always anticipated your answers
before you went on Howard you thought
you'd have some witty comeback or
confident line of deflection but you end
up getting really embarrassed and he as
he grounds you down to a nub and then he
knew he gotcha
like the late thin Karen Carpenter he'd
only just begun when you were put on the
spot which was certainly how those early
Sophists like gorges and Protagoras felt
when they fell into Socrates dialogical
trappin Ethan Athens Athens Athens s
actions you had no choice but to give in
to the moment and reveal unspeakable
truths you would never ever dare utter
in front of other humans let alone in a
most public forum this was Howard's
secret weapon at least in the days
before serious and knee cameras he
smiled the goofiest goddamn smile at me
and completely caught me off guard I was
not prepared for the kindness and in the
magical blue pools of his eyeballs there
was something safe about his as your
eyes and his grandma grin that
hypnotized me into thinking his words
were innocuous and private it was
masterful he made me feel like I was in
a guarded private discussion safe from
judgment like he was the only one who
understood my true motivation and I
spilled what little beans I had for his
mockery and amusement I cannot imagine
what else I said on that show that
morning I never listened back to the
tape partly because I wanted to
experience I wanted the experience to
remain pristine but also because I'm
sure I humiliated myself and don't want
a reminder of how much I sounded like an
ass he asked me if I wanted to get naked
since I loved him so much
no so he tapped to my stomach with the
back of his hand
said yeah you're tight nice package
there but
you have mother hips work on those
bastard it wasn't until I reflected on
what I said that as I was walking down
the hallway realizing I could never take
back the vag chat that I struck that I
started thinking oh [ __ ] what did I say
can something I said on Howard Stern get
me fired I knew my mom didn't have
Howard in Portland so I was safe on that
front but everyone at the MTV offices
and at the studio Viacom bosses
rainmakers and people with firing power
were tuned in on their way to work this
was the only thing playing in people's
cars on their commute into the city
period and it started to sink in I could
be fresh out of a job while Howard was
doing this all a sudden blow jobs and
cherries didn't seem so tasty after all
this was less than a year after how its
Fartman stunt at the 1992 Video Music
Awards a scenario he documented as a
failure
in his book private parts and later
re-enacted in the movie I didn't think
it was a failure my young love for
Howard show was still in his early blush
so he could do no wrong but there were
people at the network who were not
wildly impressed by his a/c shenanigans
I thought he used a dimply stunt ass
which to me seemed funny then I found
out that it was his real booty and I
realized that he also has mom hips
Touche moon prayer Howard was always
obsessed with MTV he was pursuing his
own TV career so this could have been a
huge galvanizing moment that launched
him into a greater stratosphere than
he'd already known instead it was funny
to fans and people who loved him but
Howard's brand of magic did not have the
same effect when he was thrust into a
series of variables beyond his control
it was live it was chaotic it was mostly
about music and it was not his show
three out of four of those elements sued
him but the third seemed to sink his
battleship not as badly as he felt but
people might have walked away confused
and not elevated I wanted so desperately
to go backstage and meet him that night
but I had not yet officially started my
job so I so I was juiceless my passes
were useless and I I'd have to wait a
year until about hot summer morning
almost a year later until I had my own
confusing moment with the king at least
I didn't have to show him my ass Lisa
Kennedy Lee